[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I used to think that I was sure of what
made people tick
strip them down right to their core and
find a self-centered I thought when the
push came to the shove I knew just what
I'd do I put me before you
but you didn't guess I didn't you can be
a cynic and a sinner who can only see
the flaws but even if you lost your way
you don't have to stay a lost cause
so can we do a little good maybe give a
little more
work a little harder than we did the day
before
it only takes a little good and so doing
what you can
taking every chance to make the choice
to be a better man so do a little good
well I have spent each Christmas Day
obsessed with wrong and right you
thought change could only work one way
it had to happen in one night
but now you know oh now you know the
line of good and bad is not so clean and
what we are is something in between it's
an everyday decision two steps forward
but if you try to do what's right you're
on the right track
[Music]
[Applause]
a chance to make the choice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and some days
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and go on
give a little more
[Applause]